a large tornado  [Music]  i'm monitoring this situation very  closely since early this morning  this is likely to be one of the largest  tornado outbreaks in our history  [Music]  it'll be a miracle  if anybody else is found  alive in it  [Music]  we're continuing to search the site for  evidence of life and will continue  recovery operations until all personnel  are accounted for we have lived through  some of the toughest  hours of our lives as kentuckians  this  event  is the worst  most devastating most deadly tornado  event in kentucky's history  [Music]  the fact is that  we all know everything is more intense  when the climate is warming everything  [Music]  we got the warnings yeah yeah we knew  it's coming but  you don't have anywhere to go you know  i raised my family here my all my kids  worked here  uh it was just this is our hometown and  it's just devastating everybody's lost  everything